according to a wall street journal
report facebook executives know that
instagram is toxic for teen girls and
have downplayed significant mental
health issues
my lord you know we we all know this
just based on first-hand experience but
using instagram
and the influence it has over young
people and even old people to create
fomo or body image issues is obvious to
anyone media is extremely powerful and
it has an incredibly detrimental effect
on your mental health so according to
the wall street journal facebook
conducted in-depth research on the
impacts of instagram on children's
mental health from 2018 to 2020 but they
never made the research public and this
is where journalism is super important
journalists
uh you know really need to sink their
teeth into this kind of stuff because
you do have bad actors like instagram
and facebook out there
nor did they make this research
available to academics or lawmakers who
previously asked for it so in other
words this is the cover-up if you've
ever seen the movie the insider i think
that's a michael mann movie uh with
russell crowe one of my top 10 favorite
films it's very similar to what happened
with the tobacco companies they had the
research they knew it
and
they hid it from people and that really
is horrific
in my mind teens children should not use
social media i'm keeping my kids off it
for as long as possible tic toc seems
the absolute worst instagram right
behind it and uh i covered facebook uh
talking about building instagram for
kids uh which i called the worst idea
ever uh on episode 12 13 in may
think about it for a second
the people at facebook
who have
children and unlimited resources to
raise those children
get reports back in in-depth research
that they are causing mental health
problems in children
not only do they not share that with
other academics not only do they try to
slow things down and have an open
discussion with public policy people no
what does facebook do they recommend
instagram for kids are you kidding me
really
you know this is going down
zuckerberg and you have kids
really and then you decide you're going
to do instagram for kids so you know
that teens and people over the
age of 13 16 are having mental health
issues and you decide let's go earlier
with the mental health issues do you
realize how deranged that is
facebook presentation slides from 2019
stated quote
we make body image issues worse for one
in three teen girls teens blame
instagram for increases in the rate of
anxiety and depression the reaction was
unprompted and consistent across all
groups according to the wall street
journal
oh my lord
can you imagine being a facebook
executive
being in a meeting
and somebody pulls up a slide that says
we make body image issues worse for one
in three teen girls
and teens blame instagram for increases
in the rate of anxiety and depression
the teens are telling you you're doing
this to them
and you're doing it to one out of three
girls this isn't one in ten it's not one
in 20 maybe you say it's a statistical
anomaly maybe the date is wrong
if they're telling you you're doing this
to them
believe them teenagers are telling you
they're ruining you're ruining their
lives with your product believe them
come up with ways to maybe uh not allow
certain types of images or to uh maybe
throttle people going viral on these
services there are things you could be
doing and at the very least you could be
putting warnings up telling parents and
maybe increasing the age at which people
start on this but that is against
zuckerberg's key key
mission
zuckerberg only cares about growth i've
been saying this for
over 10 years now i know the guy i've
met him i know the people who work for
him he has only ever cared about one
thing growth
one thing matters to zuckerberg growth
and he
is not
you know the most social of people i
don't want to diagnose him from afar but
you know when
saturday night live does skits about him
being asperger's s
and everybody kind of says this person
does not understand social dynamics you
have somebody who maybe is not very
sophisticated in social dynamics i'll
say it in a charitable way based on his
behavior not trying to diagnose him
and if that person is in charge of the
world's largest social experiment what
do we think is going to happen what
decisions do you think he's going to be
made
he's gotten the largest fines in the
history of the ftc and that's all you
need to know
you cannot trust za don't trust zuck
and you do not want these products in
your life according to the wall street
journal article about 22 million teens
log into instagram every day um they
should be banned from doing so i i think
it's that simple i think they should
just increase the age maybe it's like 17
years old um if we assume 11 million of
those are young women or girls just cut
the number in half um if one in three of
those 11 million are facing body image
issues that's 3.6 million teen girls
every day experiencing body issues
i mean it's just gross right it's super
gross how dare you
how can you live with yourself mark
zuckerberg i mean just horrific a
virginia congresswoman jennifer wexton
gave her thoughts on the matter we make
body images issue
we make body image issues worse for one
in three teen girls she did the quote
that i just read
this report is sickening it's hard
enough being a teen girl these days
facebook must get a lot more transparent
about how it serves content and the
impact of that content especially on
young women
the wall street journal also notes that
in public facebook has downplayed
instagram's negative effects on teen's
mental health that's like trusting the
cigarette companies who had doctors in
their ads and told you it was good for
circulation i mean really you're gonna
trust mark zuckerberg or facebook
executives
when they're suppressing data and
they've made every decision possible to
increase the share price by increasing
engagement even if it screws up
democracy elections and now teens mental
health and uh the quote from zuckerberg
from march of 2021 the research that
we've seen is that using social apps to
connect with other people can have
positive mental health benefits
oh my lord you know this is just shows
you how
horrible a human being zuckerberg is
the way that sentence is
phrased
is so weasely and practiced the research
we've seen right is qualifying it
is that using social apps to connect
with other people can
not does can have positive mental health
benefits so he basically doesn't talk
about kids using the app or this
depression stuff he leaves that out of
it and then he probably has some report
that some number of people had a
positive experience right sure some
people can have a positive experience
doing something dangerous of course uh
so
adam uh mosari the head of instagram
told reporters in may that research
indicated that apps effects on teens
while being likely
quite small according to the wall street
journal you know uh mar hicks is a tech
professor and she commented to the wall
street journal article companies love to
pretend they don't realize the harms
their products cause they always know
yes always
so should these type of reports be
public going forward for all social
media companies yeah i think social
media companies are having an
existential a crisis now and i think
their very existence is causing so much
damage to democracy
um to social discourse and mental health
that society will
over time
um you know recontextualize how they
operate so facebook facebook executives
you should be ashamed of yourselves and
i hope the money was worth it but
you're going to regret it on your
deathbeds the
end
was that a little too rough chat room
sorry
you'll regret it on your death beds a
little too dramatic
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business with squarespace you
know you can blog and publish content
you can promote your business you can
announce upcoming events or special
projects and you can sell products and
services of all kinds and more no matter
what the problem squarespace is the
answer they have beautiful templates by
world-class designers that's kind of
where they got started and everybody
noticing it whoa look at these beautiful
designs but they've added so much
functionality since that time including
powerful ecommerce functionality and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box it's got built-in seo
free and secure hosting and of course
their 24 7 award-winning customer
support back in 2020 we decided we
create remotedemoday.com
for founders to pitch thousands of angel
investors over resume well we purchased
the domain name remotedemoday.com and
had the site up and running within
minutes from idea to execution in just
minutes and incredible functionality so
you can grow with them and it's been a
huge success for us so far i mean we've
invested tens of millions of dollars at
kids or not so go to squarespace.com
twist for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code twist to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain and congratulations to
the team for going public on may 19th
what an amazing journey it's been
amazing to watch squarespace grow and
become such a vibrant company and
congratulations on that milestone